hello Jeff Jeff Ross is in if I would I
put it I liked it maybe it's cuz I liked
it so much more than I thought I would
it also really suffered from he was
going high but we talked about Quentin
Tarantino and the fact he's in a little
hot water yeah I don't know a lot about
what's going on he went at the defensive
hit they had an interview in 2003 on
Stern where he was defending Polanski
and he was saying you can have if you
have sex with a thirteen-year-old that
wants to have sex it's not rape it's
just a little yeah it's a little much
it's a little much but welcome is what
we're trying to say yes good to see you
guys just ready to bring you up to speed
yeah how long what do you what are you
here for you ever I see you in town you
of something coming out this time I'm at
Caroline's oh he's hanging out Friday
Saturday and Sunday to one two seven
five seven forty one hundred if the
tickets are even available it's on
Broadway it's a great club
oh yeah it's bad Thanks yeah I wasn't
sure you're promoting yeah I haven't
been here in a while
and Caroline's was calling and I was
like that'd be fun I've been on tour
with rock all year oh you have you ever
Europe and Scandinavian Tel Aviv's so I
was like I got all these new jokes let
me do Caroline's how was it it's really
fun really really fun I'm gonna miss
those big arena shows all right down on
my roots and Caroline's this weekend do
you start to get used to the arena it's
like like feeling really comfortable
like this is fun like this that walk
down the hall before you go on it's
pretty pretty amazing we do it a half
hour 20 minutes that's great but I would
bring people onstage and speed roast
them so with the Jumbotrons and the
camera oh my god rain it was like being
on a hockey team is it killing you get a
laugh the o2 arena and for the 20,000 so
the thing is like Chris I I know Chris
had Leslie Jones at one point he likes
to have somebody in front of him who
[ __ ] murders he's really a that's
like Chris a strong comic because he
wants somebody who does really well in
front of him when he's trying out when
he's but he's touring
he would literally have me bring the
house lights up in these arenas from
Oslo to Tel Aviv to London to Brooklyn
LA New Orleans like doesn't matter the
[ __ ] works everywhere bring the lights
up say who wants to come up and get
roasted needs some big Chris Rock fans
people would leap out of there see
come onstage on line them up it's just
mayhem for 10-15 minutes the whole place
is like screaming like it's at a
sporting event and then I could dismiss
him and he comes out like he loves to
follow the chaos he does right yeah
gotta get credit man yeah that's
extremely uncommon right I've never seen
it and I still didn't it took me a long
time to even understand why he was doing
it why does he do it yeah he likes to
make it strong what what what I can
understand is he likes it to be a good
show but also he likes to get the
interactive part of the show out of the
way the fans screaming yelling it all
happens when I'm up there and then
that's kind of over and his act is
really like almost a band he once you
laughing and groove him with him but
it's about him and what he wants to tell
you he's prepared for a year to tell you
this act and then the audiences of the
couples he gets a lot of couples it's
interesting how how you watch the
couples while he's performing he'll do a
joke that's five minutes long the first
two minutes like the women are laughing
and the men's hands are clenched and
then the second two minutes it's the
opposite the the men are laughing and
the women are cracking up and then for
the last minute they're all both
laughing together
he really is brings people together in a
in a great way yeah a great great
economic is that a great wingman like if
you have a date yeah why because he
talks about sex a lot of sex oh I get to
show ya yeah does that work getting all
that audience interaction done like do
people feel like okay I got that out of
my thing so and it hypes them up but it
makes them feel like they were part of
the show yeah part of the experience and
then they're ready to just concentrate
on Chris it seems like it he doesn't
have and a half it's not going to see
ac/dc like he has you imagine an hour
and a half of comedy in an arena no man
I for me an hour another hour of me and
we had in Europe this past one Michelle
wolf than Anthony Jeselnik
why is three of you in front of okay Wow
yeah so that is that's for our show
before even come then there's an
intermission like it's a it's a
nightmare it comes out after an
intermission yeah okay how long is it
mission 15 minutes to sell booze yeah
surrealism t-shirts and stuff
this fun man the Wembley Arena the o2
arena I don't know if I get that chance
again it's really fun yeah sounds like a
fun tour and he's so nuts and humble
like we literally private jets all over
Europe and Scandinavia and then we get
to London's like let's take the
underground to the o2 oh yeah how was it
it was pretty great I posted a picture
on my Instagram of me and him and the
other cop and Michelle and Anthony on
the subway going to the o2 arena do
people notice him oh yeah yeah yeah he
can't go anywhere
I mean he's super famous he really is
right yeah so you're back are you done
with that tour or hold we just finished
in London last weekend Sunday night at
the o2 last show what's the longest
shirt at any city 36 hours and Tel Aviv
that was a big I've never been in Israel
how is it I think you would love it man
I got offered a gig there recently
before London but it was just too much
and I would have been in and out too
fast and I didn't want to just I didn't
want to do that much flying yeah I want
to spend like three or four days if I go
you'd have to go a day in a couple days
in and absorb it because you'd be
wanting to talk about what you're seeing
you know people the beaches are
beautiful the food the people all the
things you can imagine Plus on top of
that the crowds laugh and live like it
could be their last day on earth
so everything's hilarious and they're
not stuck up at all oh good crowd so you
can really rip in the subjects deep I'm
smart and they're politically aware and
socially aware and like if I said Trump
they'd know who he was the other thing
all over Europe right now
and Israel when we did talked about
everything we all the comics talked
about Trump and people really eat it up
they just want to hear all that stuff no
you know you're Jewish so had you been
there before I've been in Israel like
seven eight years ago I did some
benefits there but nothing on the scale
that I went with this time did it mean
anything to you and you went like you'd
like oh [ __ ] I'm it gives you some a
good warm feeling I'm not a religious
person I've always sort of like rolled
my eyes or religion and been very
skeptical of religion but then when you
get there and it's not religion it's
more cultural everyone looks like me
yeah my mom this is now range you know
everyone from the President to like the
guy who picked up my
bangs at the airport kind of looks like
me so I go wow this is sort of not a
selling point for Israel Jeff soon as I
left they started fighting for the land
again but you do feel a connection I
guess I was in Ireland for a couple days
I kind of understand like why this is I
guess where I am from if they didn't
feel it didn't wasn't like a
sledgehammer but you are you I think the
majority I have a little Italian German
maybe but I think the majority my
grandmother used to tell me a little bit
about our heritage I'm kind of curious
for the sake of being curious I want to
learn a little bit yeah and you know and
the food is so good in essence you're
learning a whole nother culture do you
go to the wall or anything like that
I went years ago we don't have time this
time but I did manage to drag Chris out
for lunch to Jaffa the old city and
we're getting my friend Anna is from she
works for the Knesset in Jerusalem she's
Orthodox Jew like an old college friend
of mine she's now Orthodox Jew wears a
wig you know and she has five kids and
she's very religious and you know one of
the guys went to shake her hand I
remember was Anthony or Chris and she
recoiled and I'm sorry I don't touch men
and we all looked at each other because
we'd been talking about harassment the
whole flight over and we realized oh
okay Israel's now in the future not the
past
yeah yeah we're going back to that
culture of no more touching women was
she's but she was happy to see you
oh yeah oh yeah they came to the show a
lot of Israeli celebrities who we don't
know and the spokesman for Benjamin
Netanyahu came and Wow it was pretty fun
actually it was like you know a cultural
awakening
I dig oh I've heard I got offered that
one gig and I actually do want to go but
I want to go and I can spend three or
four days and actually go around but the
idea is I and we watch the news it's
scary to think that you could be in a
cafe and someone runs in when a bomb
belly just frightens me it's just not
happening it's just not happening not
one second of scared at all are you are
once you're there you're not thinking
anymore
watch this Dalian happens in Tel Aviv
all happens here it's no different not
suicide bombings that's her I'm not
crazy as you say it does happen there
and it's frightening there because there
are people plowing into
Time Square I'm not saying we don't have
terrorism here I'm just saying what
scares me for some reason that doesn't
scare me as much even though you'd be
dead the idea of I guess kid my whole
life I've always known that there was a
threat of a car hitting you yeah so this
is just all righty guys doing it on
purpose as opposed to being drunk it's
scary
but in my crazy mind I'm like I can
avoid that I'd run you know maybe you
can't it's probably also because you
live here of course right but suicide
bombing just scares me most of the
contention is is out in Jerusalem and
the West Bank in Tel Aviv you're kind of
like it's like going to Brooklyn 30
years ago but it's on the beach and
everyone's beautiful and you know all
the time that are wearing army uniforms
and they strip them down with their guns
and go to the beach and the food is
amazing and I went I got in and we got
in early the night before early enough
for me to hit a comedy club so I did a
set in English for people who speak
broken English and got to warm up a
little bit how was it so even if you
were there three four days you could
probably like work out and have some fun
were the people receptive to you or no
oh yeah they were crowd was phenomenal
no no I mean in the clubs you went yeah
yeah no they weren't they were very
happy to see me and and it's weird you
know the accents all over this is just
happening with American comedy the
globalization of American comedy I'll go
to the Oslo or Stockholm and I'll walk
around all day and I barely understand
what people are saying to me
and even when I speed rose people though
like I have trouble with the accents and
the references but they understand
everything I say yeah I guess so you
write globalization of comments go to
look at or just American movies or
whatever it is probably Netflix has done
a lot for it for comedy because the
movies have always been shown yeah but I
guess you're right they'd be the comedy
is helping so can Chris Rock not like
enjoy any of these cities at all I made
him go to oh the old city Inn in Israel
I mean he tolerates my sightseeing a
little bit but you know he finally did
celebrate for real in London when after
the years he was like alright I gotta go
I mean I just did the o2 two nights in a
row so yeah he's not to go out and enjoy
but he's probably worried about the next
gig or like alright I got to do this and
do that yeah it was the end of the tour
so he had no excuse to go out and have a
little bit of fun how long is it worth
he went he did a hundred and
50 shows last year oh wow I did like I
don't know maybe 30 or 40 of them you
didn't do the us she just did that I did
quite a few of us I did la New York the
garden Barclays the Dolby in LA like
don't you let me pick the ones I wanted
to do so I picked the juice oh that's
fun just take place you want to go with
Rihanna New Orleans when you're a part
of something like that do you start and
now you're going back on your on your
solo tour do you start to like
restructure in your head like what do I
have to do yeah
to get there or do you just like okay
back to doing what I do
it's inspiring and also like tiring I
watched him going this is all about him
he's living an hour and a half he's
making zillions he's gotta be making 20
30 grand show you do everything like
that I can't even imagine the feeling of
me of making that money and hitting that
hard you know he calls it his divorce
tour because he was making up for his
lost time but um you know what he really
is the best he really is the best comic
his act is fire it's so good he's really
when you watch him and you see his take
on it what's so good about him is you
never like the angles are unpredictable
like one minute he'll say something that
you'd expect him to say in another
minute he says something you totally
don't expect him to say it's like it's
it's like he's a complete person he's
not he's not like some [ __ ] uh you
know they taught like identity politics
like I don't think there's any of that
you feel like there's just a guy
expressing real opinions some that
you'll expect some you won't it's very
unpredictable yeah he doesn't always
take the popular no yeah right I love
that I love that he loves to build the
tension you'll see tension rising and
people's like leaning in like going
where is this going this is making me
uncomfortable he's talking about
cheating or or divorce and people start
to get you know they're on a date and
suddenly like he finds that pressure
valve release and everybody is kind of
in on it and lows it did he shoot any of
this - he did he did he shot it for a
Netflix special awesome yeah one show
two shows in one place he's shot in
Brooklyn a couple of months ago kind of
been a low-key theater oh he didn't
publish
now it wasn't the barclays at the end of
the year and it was probably one of the
best shows I've ever had and it's but
that's not the one he taped for Netflix
the other one is a small theater in
Brooklyn and that wasn't like hey come
to a taping it was just now yeah he
released tickets for like a few hundred
people and did like a more intimate
special how many shows what you mean one
or two shows did you for the special he
taped a couple yeah it's always the way
it is gonna tape a couple well you got
it tape one you [ __ ] I don't do that
my last special I had one shot at it
that's different I've talked about you
when you weren't even here that that's
an odd anomaly and the fact that you did
that like you really are and I've said
this to you and without and about you
you're like you're like a Renaissance
comic like you do things that no one
else is doing you really mean that like
you go places that no one else is going
prisoners cops it's like none of these
are easy getting order the border into
Juarez like it's it's pretty amazing to
walk thanks Jimmy I mean that it's it's
[ __ ] fascinating that you have the
balls to do these I wish I had Jeff's
comfort level and balls because I've
seen you in situations where you walk in
and you're just comfortable attempting
to be funny meaning you're usually very
funny yeah but you're not ashamed of
being funny or of saying things to be
funny like I don't know that it's hard
to describe yeah I'm so wrapped up in my
own head and you there's a freedom to
you that I just admire thank you do you
feel like you swinging just take a swing
that's it right do you feel like after
you're in a position where I mean you
just put yourself in a position where
you're dying like when you're in that we
talked about it I think the last time
you were in or a couple times ago when
you're in that room full of cops that
are just they would refuse to give you
anything you're not going to give you
anything and like you still did it do
you come out of that feeling like okay
I'm stronger for that well you know in
that particular show you're talking
about when I did Jeff Ross roasts cops I
roasted the Boston Police Department
thinking they'd be very happy to see me
because I'm showing their side of the
job and you know they were very
skeptical and I thought they were gonna
love me and they really didn't like me
they really you know you can look this
up on iTunes or whatever
but how long was the show an hour that
particular appearance was like 20
minutes and cut down to 6 minutes and it
feels like it's 7 hours I mean it was an
office yeah all I said was a 1 out of 6
minutes no I did a full special about
the particular scene that Sam's talking
about is it a roll call
yeah I'm went to a morning roll call
with a bunch of jokes thinking oh I'll
lighten up their day
laughs with some you know take a few
funny shots and they just stared I'm
just trying to do Tom Brady jokes and
Whitey Bulger is from Boston I said if
his name was Blackie Bolger he would
have found him in five minutes looks
like that word haven't it they were cops
like to get the last word they're not
really looking to be the butt of a joke
right yeah especially not from some
[ __ ] and I'm going in there Hollywood
fruit they were skeptical of me because
I'd been in a black lives matter rally
actually the one where Quentin Tarantino
it's right it's a very incendiary words
about the police yes and when they
googled me the Union guys googled me and
I got up there they saw that I was at
that rally they thought well I'm playing
you know I'm duping them that I'm
actually with an agenda when in fact I
said I went there to do research to make
this a fair-minded sure even minded
piece otherwise it's just fluff and no
one's gonna want to watch it you got to
see both sides of this issue by the way
neither side was ever talking to each
other like the whole black lives matter
mantra was which side are you on
and then when I get to the cops they
kind of said are you with us or against
us so no one's actually talking to each
other and that was sort of the mission
of the show so at the end of this set
did you wind up winning them over were
you I did have to go back a month and a
half later the balls and I said that's a
really tough train ride up there believe
me he didn't want to do it I was just
scared because I'd already bombed a
bunch of time same guy he do yeah but by
now I got to new I got to know them a
little bit so I came into it with a
little bit of credibility and that I
actually researched even harder exactly
what they do and what do you want a
piece of [ __ ] well I was wonder if they
were pieces of [ __ ] and they were
wondering if I was a piece of [ __ ] okay
you know policing right now and
especially a year and a half ago and I
was doing this was a
the tough topic to take on because
everybody's super sensitive out and
there was a lot of protest there was a
lot of violence is right now heat of the
Freddie gray
Trotta and all the cops wanted to talk
about that stuff so I basically set up
laughs Boston as a police precinct like
decked it out just sort of customized
for the cops so they wouldn't feel weird
with their uniforms on in the audience
and I had everything from Molly you
brought them into an audience yeah oh
not a general audience was just for them
no nobody's Oh nuts and coffee that's
like the moment where you figure out if
you're gonna have this room or not like
if you come out before you go on and
they're like looking at you like a piece
of [ __ ] because it's coffee and
doughnuts yeah then you're like oh you
instead of doing in the station house
you had them go to a comedy club how'd
you deck it out what you do they just
put like you know blue piping or
everywhere and and and you know I kind
of took the lights down a little bit and
put some pictures of some classic Boston
police sure imagery and we set up a
little podium and Commissioner Evans the
the police chief was a really
interesting guy there smart guy
lifelong Boston cop he introduced me
because he was kind of on board with the
message I was trying to offer you know
because when I was a kid I they respect
yeah yeah but he's always at odds with
the Union so the unions were always like
kind of poking at me and messing with me
and he would be like Oh Jeff's fine let
him try it
so when I was able to like roast the
commissioner a little bit it kind of
disarmed everybody literally and and
they went with me on the hour-long
journey oh when you were on stage yeah
what well let me see a picture of this
guy the Commissioner what's his name
Commissioner Evans aw you should
definitely look at this guy he probably
a lifelong Boston cop he's probably a
guy that doesn't tolerate a lot of [ __ ]
no I wouldn't imagine it's worth looking
up by the way they let me do it because
the Boston PD hasn't shot an unarmed
person since 1991 oh wow
that's him yeah yeah it looks almost
like he looks like a UH he looks to me
like an Irish cop who does not [ __ ]
around but the point is that marathons
of course he does oh my god does he look
like a
yeah he's definitely he looks like
Freddy Krueger with a badge the point of
the special though is to get that across
right that there's like there's not this
Boston cop violence thing going on and
and you know some people in the
community would argue that they get
profiled and pulled over for no reason
but the truth is a detective in the I
believe it was in the gang unit was shot
the morning I got there so that's also
why they were stone-faced me they were
not so a guy was shot the morning I
started filming so they were all like on
very tense and high alert and the cops
found the guy that shot the cop and they
didn't kill him
they used restraint and you got to give
him credit a cop gets shot yeah I think
the cops would just shoot the guy they
didn't then shot him in the you know
they arrested him alive so props to the
BPD for letting me come in yes I highly
recommend you check that one out if you
care about this kind of issue
these are but they're just the toughest
audiences the cops prisoners the border
like you literally can't pick a harder
place just to a hospice did you give any
other like give it another celebrity
roast coming up I feel like it's been a
while since in a while yeah you know we
had we had a couple people like Puss out
so we were right back oh really and then
stuff happens in their lives or like I
better not do this who was it no comment
now but um who'd be good to do it now I
mean I guess getting like the Kardashian
mom up there would be an easy one Steve
Wayne like I have roasted Steve Wynn
before you have really great rows in
Beverly Hills at the Friars years ago
and I remember like he has this
degenerative eye disease and I remember
really understanding the power of Don
Rickles at that event because I went on
I did my thing all the comics were doing
really well Steve Wynn beloved casino
magnate and we're all being very
reverential sure and and finally at the
end Rickles
goes on and he just goes for the
elephant in the room he just starts
waving his hands in front of Steve
Wynn's face and goes I'm over here I'm
over here see laughs oh my god he was
crying out of those out of those broken
eyes beautiful moment was funny yeah did
he prepare for to just go up and Rickles
seemed to like to improvise these things
I don't even think he thought it through
very well and as a matter of fact the
couple of times I did a roast with him
where I was prepared like reading I
remember like a John Stamos's fiftieth
birthday a private event we're all
dressed up in tuxedos it's fancy hotel
Sunset Tower Hotel and John said calls
me a couple days before he's like will
you please roast me for my 50th please
please please I go all right so of
course you know I work on it you know
how we do yeah so I write a bunch of
jokes I come in with a page and a half
you know John Stamos is so good-looking
his birthday candles blow themselves
yeah just whatever joke about full house
and this and that and I'd killed and
then Rickles goes on after me in his
first two minutes are making fun of me
for preparing breaking how did you feel
when but then the ultimate the ultimate
the ultimate lesson there is when Don
finally passed away I was in his funeral
and was very honored to be invited
obviously worshipped Don Rickles and
just at the end of the ceremony they
handed me a microphone and said say
something and now here I am unprepared
it's almost like Don got the last laugh
yeah what did you say I pulled it out
and I told some stories about Don that
that I had never told me four different
times and what one time at Milton
Berle's funeral
I loved Milton Berle he was just so
funny and yeah I never met her in TOR to
me and it's a great guy and it's very
emotional funeral and I remember after I
had to pee the whole time I had a pee is
like a long drive to the thing then you
get there just in time and the
ceremony's starting and I mean millions
of speakers and I remembered from Buddy
Hackett funeral that right behind the
the where the car you know the front of
the the funeral parlor there's a private
little for the
family bathroom like a little powder
room that's like you know as soon as the
ceremony is over everyone leans I'm
gonna not get online in the men's room
I'm gonna go for that powder room I know
where it is you know nobody's gonna know
where that is I'm running right for it
so soon as everybody starts heading
towards this cemetery to bury the coffin
I go to this powder room and I'm in
there maybe 60 seconds just to pee wash
my hands zip up I opened the door and
Don Rickles is standing there with his
hands on his hips like he's been waiting
for 45 minutes and he looks at me and he
goes what was here a dais in there I
knew I knew I had a reputation for the
roast guy in that moment that's funny
how did you feel you you are stood the
Charlie Sheen roast right oh yeah how
did you feel about that word Patrice had
his set right well kind of yeah I mean
that just made me think of it when you
said Rickles didn't always have you know
everything planned out that's where
Patrice kind of gave up on his material
and just started going and had this like
amazing classic thing did you realize
when it was happening like this is huh I
knew before it was happening because you
know I was um I was a producer on that
show and really pushed Patrice to do the
roast he'd been turning me down for
years yeah
he'd always say well I wanted somebody I
know or somebody I'm friends with I'm
like well that's a cop-out you know
exactly what Charlie Sheen is and this
would be a really good idea why he
actually didn't want to do him know I
think he was being sincere he just did
what he wanted to do yeah he wanted a
roast a friend and he didn't care about
flavor flavor or whoever we did the year
before I don't know but I remember
talking to Patrice before the show and
he was going last and we needed a real
closer and Patrice wasn't an opening act
he was a guy who could come clean up
mm-hmm and I knew that and he's like
he's like sort of he looked right on the
red carpet just all leather jacket
leather matching hat he look like a
[ __ ] rock star he's just like but he
was like cranky backstage and he's like
I don't like my material and why do I
got to go last and none of my friends
are here I go Patrice let's make some
new friends tonight what are you looking
at all this negative [ __ ] for he's like
well
I gotta go last and I don't like these
jokes I didn't write these jokes I go
your last [ __ ] the jokes roast the roast
just pay attention
huh you don't need to hit every line who
cares be funny you're funny in any
situation I said just make it yours just
own the room just stay up he does well
they only give me five minutes I said
stay up there till you do you feel like
your guilt your last he's like well if I
get in trouble I'm gonna tell him you
that you know no you're not getting in
trouble you got it you only get in
trouble if you if you bomb nowhere you
go long I go just go up there and roast
the roast just look at everything and
it's exactly what he did
he criticized everybody's career but
what they did that night right as a
jumping-off point and if he hit a few
beats and he planned maybe but for the
most part he created a moment like he
summed up the show which I thought was
brilliant he was actually a cleanup
hitter yeah and that's what you want out
of those things right sick Jude I mean
the whole point is to create moments and
he was so happy afterward he was yeah
people say he came home and he
complained about this and that let me
tell you something he came out with us
he was so happy afterwards it was the
happiest I've ever seen him that's
awesome cuz you didn't see I mean it's
only a roasting piece was it when you
when you would see him like if he would
have a good set would you see him like
be outwardly happy about it you know it
was always hard to tell ya it was always
hard to tell how early we didn't work
that much together at the end like you
know cuz again he was headlining I was
headlining so for you if we didn't do
but if he had a good set yeah he'd be
happy about it but you could never tell
because he would always if he didn't
have a good set he would behave like he
had gotcha he would behave like he had
had a good set and have the same
arrogance so you could never tell when
he was just pretending to feel good
and when he was genuinely happy that he
had had a truly good set and what is
definition of a good set is probably
different than most comedians to like
was he killing or did he make his point
or yeah did he do what he wanted to do
you know my my most memorable and favor
I loved Patrice we were good pals but
our our best most memorable
conversations were always he
arguments and it reminds me I'm going to
Caroline's is this week and a lot of
them were in that green room at
Caroline's
oh right I remember this none of this
will sound good 15 years later but it's
like you know Patrice
do you really need to when you open for
me do you really need to do that act out
of a Down syndrome person for five
minutes like it's a little much right
when the show starts and he'd get so bad
but I know you know I know in one minute
you're defending that bit but then in an
hour you'll tell me how come you're not
doing television more and I go you know
it's a long time ago before we had the
freedom we have and he got it and he
would make adjustments another time he's
like people don't take me seriously I'm
like well you're 38 years old and you're
wearing a football jersey in shorts
onstage but what happens if you dress
like a man tomorrow mm-hmm let's just
see what happens and how you feel and
then he would come in dressed up and
he'd he'd give me the side-eye
afterwards like you were right you know
like I felt like he was open to
adjustments if they came from the right
angle and the right person yeah if he
respected the individual if he respected
your opinion yeah we were just uh and he
loved a good chick story like if you
came in the next day and you were like
he was like what happened owes chicks
less I mean he really got delighted at
all that yeah he's a pig long fingers do
you remember those fingers watch them
work miracles [ __ ] meet girls of
course it was so is he happy after that
like after he had a great session where
the woman was he happy
he was really good and I remember me and
Keith Robinson we're fighting in Brazil
we're arguing about something I loved it
that trip existed by the way three of
them
it's amazing three of them this one was
being Keith arguing about some I like
some girl - no but you know just give me
[ __ ] and we were just arguing and
Patrice was like look I see both your
points you know he was basically saying
that when I'm here that's my fantasy is
to fall in love you know that's his
fantasy your fantasy is to do and he
made great sense we finally stopped
arguing but he was a good arbiter a lot
of times
or arbitrator and those stupid pointless
arguments you'd have with with friends
we were just fighting I think as I
wanted the love experience and I met
this girl named Fabiana who uh I didn't
[ __ ] her I just loved her she spoke
English uh-huh and she'd leave at night
and play [ __ ] 30 people
I really wasn't dumb American people
don't like your hat my hat there's being
criticized I got it in Copenhagen
Denmark I love it don't see a lot of
orange had a reason yeah you don't know
what color on my first Firebird is I had
a burnt orange Firebird when I was a kid
do you still take karate
no I was talking about recently you're a
black dog karate I am doesn't fit around
my waist anymore yeah I mean Newark New
Jersey you had to learn some how to
something tailor karate as a kid uh-huh
Wow wait at what point did you get black
belt I grew up in Newark and there was
no phys ed in my poor town so my mom
dragged me to karate school at six and a
half and by ten and a half eleven I was
a black belt really yeah did you ever
have to use it yeah you did she got into
fights as a kid I was more like I would
stop fights or um or stick up for like
kids like we're getting bullied but I
don't think I like got in fights where
are you still did you like continue your
training are you way out of training I'm
Way out of training yeah but I feel like
if somebody came at me I could defend
myself
you could you have some may say away
from me yeah like like if I flinch I
don't flinch like I'm gonna get hit i
flinch like I'm gonna defend myself yeah
that's interesting do you watch like
yeah MMA or internet stuff or any
physical combat sports no I've been
getting into a WWE lately oh you have
it's a little different sure yeah but I
was here the other day when it was a
bunch of wrestlers here yeah couple o
couple Fridays ago Eric Bischoff was
here and JBL abl was here Bruce Prichard
yeah Jeff came in oh okay
hang out for a little bit yeah I was
away you JBL the favorite thing you've
ever announced my favorite thing you've
ever announced was your retirement
[Laughter]
sometimes like I was reading the room
when you did that and wrestlers are
sometimes like cops in the way that
they're not really used to being the
butt of the joke here pretty fun
actually they laugh oh yeah yeah
it's the worst when you say [ __ ] you
go for it and bomb some yeah someone at
home was laughing though yeah I always
figured someone at home
somebody's enjoying it I thought it was
funny yeah I was doing it I wasn't here
to Jeff see Caroline's by the way
Thursday through Sunday yeah two one two
seven five seven forty one hundred it's
not 50th and Broadway great Club I'm
guessing one Thursday one Sunday to
Friday to Saturday it's correct whoa
yamaneika saunders and Amisha Patel
uh-uh all I know is it my Miescher
Nimish ninny mini-mesh in that [ __ ] I
know I'm well I've said something last
night actually he wants to come on the
show he's really I like him a lot great
guys right on out live gage great we
could have a funny show and I think
that's how we'll come by and maybe some
special guests it's fun
Caroline's haven't been here in a while
let me fun yeah it's a fun Club yeah I
haven't are you and you're doing stuff
with the towel after this like in March
right yeah they're not a little tour
then I do a gig in Aspen in two weeks by
myself and then it's hell bumping mics
comedy team of Jeff and Dave we were
hitting Portland Seattle Tahoe
you guys onstage at the same time I
gotta yeah Bethlehem Pennsylvania go to
roastmaster general calm for those
states Mina tell go on as a team you
know I've done that with him very
briefly we did we co-headlined dates
which meant I tried to just sign after
me and this was just being him and he's
so much fun to be on the road with but
then at the end when I would come up
like to close out there like yeah he
would go on after me I would go on he'd
go on and then I was just come on second
either and we would talk for like five
or ten minutes he's a really really
[ __ ] fast funny dude I wouldn't want
to do an hour with him I mean how do you
do
do you guys figure out a routine
together or you know we just had this
discussion we've never had pre-show
meetings and I said if we're gonna start
taking this to the next level we should
talk for three minutes before we go on
normally he won't even his we did this
in Montreal three nights in a row at the
festival his flip phone didn't even work
up there I did not he speak to him and
walked onstage so we had no plan uh-huh
so now we talk for two minutes in it and
it's basically yeah ask me where I was
last last week and I'll tell you know
and
and after half an hour maybe I'll leave
to smoke a cigarette okay I did he'll
leave me up there by myself or something
it'll come back with like a box of
donuts for the audience it's really very
generous in that way but you know he
keeps me on my toes he's it's like it's
like McEnroe and Jimmy Connors just
volleying he he it's really tough to
keep up with him but I hold my own he is
uh somebody that may applaud me Jaffa
Jordan or Jorge in Toronto what's up
buddy hey I was wearing if you guys knew
that the what the YouTuber idubbbz is a
huge opening anthony fan he's one of the
biggest youtubers on the planet is he um
I think I saw a picture somebody ahead
of me and hammy I know who he is I don't
watch much I'm gonna youtube it is but I
do know who this guy is yeah he's really
he is a very popular guy yeah millions
of followers he gets millions of views
on all his videos and he's kind of like
the jock tober of YouTube he poses or
the youtubers for bad content he makes
fun of other guys where's the droids
people's careers where is he from uh I'm
not sure
Oh is he okay yeah I think somebody
showed me a picture of me and him from
I'm not sure where it was from but I did
see that and I do know who he is yeah no
I've heard that that's a series of
content cop check out content cop on
Jake Hall on Jake Paul who's Jake Paul
is another content creator so oh ok
content brother what's that Oh Logan
that's right ok that's right oh yeah
Logan Paul by adding Logan Paul got so
much [ __ ] and he really shouldn't have
he's kind of a dude I think it would I
know but this is not you know what do
that they're trying to like write the
guy's career overs took joy in watching
him yeah oh because he's kind of a
douche bag thank you I appreciate it
yeah you know it's one of those things
you know that shift that suicide of you
yeah I thought he handled it very well
like that he was literally a real moment
and why the [ __ ] shouldn't he be able to
show it [ __ ] the news does the
[ __ ] news shows nothing but dead
bodies and this guy does it makes real
commentary what the [ __ ] then I had no
problems probably the minion had that he
was wearing at the time that didn't help
yeah putting it in the thumbnail and
like yeah it also in the states where he
brags about how much money he has you're
right that thought
take two yeah that was a thumbnail it
was like literally a picture of the
corpse was in the thumbnail to thing it
was almost I click here is important
yeah yeah that was in poor taste
yeah but again he's alright so he
handled something too young guy yeah but
then the Hat was not good either but it
was still the message I thought was
pretty good and the fact that they
wanted to ruin him over it was annoying
I did people just want to ruin him in
general probably that's what happens
that's what we do I mean at that age
aren't you supposed to learn a lesson
yeah you shouldn't lose everything right
of course not no make mistakes and then
when you see that dead body you take
your hat off I think I say dick out yeah
yeah even if it's a cartoon alien hat
like you have to yeah dick was already
out here to put it back so are you are
you involved now are you single oh yeah
are you are single you dating with
dating not nothing serious right now do
you like that or no I'd rather be in a
relationship you know me I like to dig
in are you a cheater you're pretty
honest guy in a relationship right I've
gotten all that out of my system you
have right I've done every bad thing but
I feel like I'm I don't know I've come
through that side of my life
did you ever get caught cheating yeah
how'd you get caught the way that all
guys get caught something on social
media
oh no I've never got because for me it's
been I've literally it's been quite a
while I never had a social media thing
but it was my fall or something like
that I mean I love your how you got
caught with the texting just totally I
know you've done hundreds a humiliating
I I was I was talking dirty with someone
and I [ __ ] hit the wrong button and I
printed out the entire conversation and
my girlfriend found it in the printer
seven page PDF of me talking dirty to
another girl [ __ ] printed his text by
Mossad the whole thing on paper I mean
it's it's the greatest it's one of my
favorite time coded
it's so awesome it's what I'm like it's
one of the great so what happens next
she she she woke me up I she find it
right away
she found the next morning she had to
get something in the printer and she
didn't know and she happened to look
through the papers she was gonna do
something with and saw this and she
almost gave it to somebody else by
mistake and I firm the only thing that
saved me was the fact that she could
tell by the text conversation that me
and the other girl had never met up
she could see that I was intriguing and
talking dirty and saying come on baby
I'll pick trying to pay her but she
could tell that the girl and I had never
met and that was the only reason I
firmly believe she did I think she would
have stabbed me in my sleep or broke my
[ __ ] jaw or something she was so mad
but that's the only thing that stopped
her I think from him in the face it was
it was flirting more than actually it
was hardcore perverted talk but she knew
that we hadn't met right the only thing
I had going for me but you were gonna
meet her I don't know if I would ever
know I'm crazy with the phone intriguing
like literally I say things in fact I
would never do I'm a time waster right
did you get caught DMing or yeah yeah Oh
No how'd she find it did you just see on
your phone her computer didn't work and
she's like can I borrow your iPad and I
hadn't used it in a year I was like here
I don't use this thing oh boy of course
it opens right up to and also stuff are
you sharing from the stupid iCloud but I
don't even know what happened man it was
what yeah your DMS go across all your
devices they should call me at work was
like what the [ __ ] can you come home
yeah stuff and did you go home oh yeah
no I we moved in together
you just have to double down yeah
Eva did you apologize like I'm so sorry
I'm a horse
and by the way I look at it now is like
the one of the great mistakes in my life
why the digging Lou a good relationship
I see oh I heard a good Peart a good
woman well but you stayed with it for a
while I could have thought we didn't I
think there was never the same after
that yeah ours wasn't neither ours
wasn't either after that whole thing it
was just by then we were already kind of
shot but I mean when you break trust
like that dude this again with the
phones it's really hard I would never do
that again I learned my lesson
and I was just too cocky and - you know
what it is here's the thing and I'm
learning this as I as I moved through
life like love is so rare we all know
that like it's not necessarily gonna
show up again so you have it keep it
precious and make sure you don't mess
that up or lose it yeah I was talking to
to somebody about that
is common but Lorraine's rare there was
talking about like being in a
relationship and how hard it is not to
cheat when they're used to being
promiscuous you know and I was like the
thing that'll trick you is that you'll
get comfortable in your relationship and
you'll forget that actually finding
somebody that you get along with is
totally uncommon like you'll just take
that for granted and you've gone
whatever I'll [ __ ] one of these other
chicks and I'll find somebody else like
that and it's like oh wait I forgot it
took me years to find this you know hard
I can't just go find another one well
you can bang anyone you want right
marrying or a relationship is a whole
nother thing and that is really hard to
find that's that's the diamond it's like
I frequently say love is a rare gem to
be cherished and polished see that's
what I'm saying weird that means wordy I
have to say often yeah some say love it
is a river do you ever meet listeners in
person and go well you know that's
somebody I would date yeah I have I've
met some really normally they might I
don't attract singles I track couples
uh-huh so you know they're very you know
sure I've made I bet girls who who were
for show well sure or whatever have you
ever had sex with somebody who hates the
show that must be fun no but I'll tell
you one thing I've [ __ ] people who
love the show until we [ __ ]
[Laughter]